Let's try to summarize what we've done so far.
We started with the initial question,
how popular were the different brands of candy?
We then thought about,
what sort of quantities should we use to make this question quantitative.
Interselection time, total number of selections.
And we ended up going with interselection time.
With a way to quantify the problem in hand,
we then had to cast the question as a rigorous statistical inference problem,
such as confidence sets or classification.
We ended up going with point estimation.
Specifically, we chose to create a regression estimator in which,
given the candy and the particular choice number,
what is the interselection time of that candy?
Specifically, how long has it been since someone chose that particular candy.
Previously, we took a look at some plots of interselection time for
individual candies.
Let's examine multiple plots on the same graph at once.
Here is depicted the interselection times of Rolo and
Reese's, with Reese's in blue and Rolo in green.
As you can see, the average interselection time of Reese's starts out lower, but
jumps a bit at the end.
And vice-versa for Rolo.
Recall that lower interselection time corresponds to higher demand.
And conversely, higher interselection time corresponds to lower demand.
Thus Reese's starts out in high demand, but
then gradually gets selected less and less often.
Conversely, Rolo starts out in low demand, and
gradually becomes selected more often.
This plot lends some support to the notion that, in fact,
there is some interaction between different brands of candy in the candy bowl.
If true, this should not be very surprising.
The brands of candy do not sit in the candy bowl in isolation.
A person's choice of a particular candy is influenced by the presence of
other candies in the bowl.
If, in fact, people preferred one brand of candy overall to another,
then you'd expect the time between selections for
one brand to be low at the same time the other was high.
As the first one starts to be depleted, the interselection time for
the second type starts to go down.